في مقطع فيديو متداول وخارب الدنيا لزعيم
مليشي حزب الله حسن نصر الله خلونا نسمع
ونشوفه مع بعض
هل لبنان اهم اوروبا من مصر
هل لبنان اهم للسعوديه من مصر
هل لبنان اهم
للخليج من مصر
200 مليار و300 مليار
يحسبوا حالهم يلعبوا فوتبول
في دوله عربيه
بس معنى لا رونالدو ميسي
قبل ما اتكلم ولا علق في فيديو ثاني حابه
اذكركم فيه بس بالله هذه المره ركزوا
واسمعوا كويس
السطح
موازنه حزب الله
ومعاشاته ومصايفه واكله وشربه وسليحه
وصواريخه من الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
طالما ايران في فلوس
يعني نحن في عندنا فلوس
ومالنا المقرر لنا يصل الينا
يا سلام يا سلام طيب ايوه بالضبط هذا هو
نفس الشخص لكن في زمنين مختلفين كان في
الاول شايف نفسه وبيتفاخر بدعم ايران له
يا ارض اشتدي ما عليك جدي واليوم بدون خجل
وبكل جراه بيتسول الدعم المالي من دول
الخليج وخصوصي من السعوديه لا لا وبيقول
البلد على حافه الانهيار طيب مو من عمايلك
هو على حافه الانهيار هو كده انهار لوحده
يعني البلد انهارت من وراء تمويل وتدريب
العصابات الارهابيه والمعسكرات وغيره
بالنشاطات حزب الله وعلى فكره في نقطه
مهمه ابغى اقول لها يعني في الفيديو
القديم اللي شايف نفسه فيه في الدعم الدعم
الايراني بيقول مدام في في فلوس في ايران
فا نحن امورنا بخير طيب تفضل روح ليش ما
بتطلب منهم يعني خلاص خلصت فلوسي ايران
وقلت خلينا نغير المسار ونطلب الدعم من
دول الخليج
الخلاصه يا جماعه بيلخصها يعني صراحه
المثل اللي بيقول ان لم تستحي فافعل ما
شئت لكن عشان نفهم اكثر يعني راح نحاول
نفهم قرائب نصر الله بس انه يعني خلينا
نحاول على الاقل يعني معنا من واشنطن
الناشط السياسي اللبناني جينو رعيدي اهلا
فيك معنا همم يعني تحول صراحه همم
مضحك مثير للسخريه يعني عجيب ما نبقى
نستخدم كمان كده الفاظ اكثر من كده
يستحقها هذا التحول بس ايش رايك
برايي هذا الشيء اللي عم يعملوا حزب الله
صار له فتره يعني حزب الله يشغلته سياسه
الاتزان
شو عم يصير بلبنان ومثل ما تفضلت وقلت انه
من وراء صار لانهيار بس وقت يمكن حاس انه
النظام بايران بطل كثير ماشي حاله قال انه
بركي لازم نقله بنجرب ناخذ مصاري من
الخليل من السعوديه بس الناس هو اخر كم
سنه يعني جرب بيعمل ان امتي كانه العدو
الاول للبنان تحت امره حزب الله هو دول
الخليج اللي هو منه شيء بس وقت شويه
النظام
وهي مش اول مره بيعمل هيك نصر الله متذكر
اول الثوره اللبنانيه 2019 طلع هو عن
الاشخاص
بتتذكر وقت قال انه احنا ما راح نجوع وراح
نضل الدولار
كثير الرنانه متنقش شرقا منتجه ما باعرف
وين بعد يعني ولا مره بنشوف اكشن بينعمل
هذا الافكار تبعون الرنانه وصلولهن حكمين
لبنان ويلي ما يلي ما بيحكي مثل ما هن
بدهم ينقتل يعني لقمان سنين مش من زمان
[موسيقى]
كل يومين ثلاثه
كل هدف طبعا الحزب الله اللي هو تصدير
الكابتن جون ده دول الخليج هلا زعلان بده
منه المصاري ثم وقف قتليست
على الهدوء الانظمه هلا منه
[موسيقى]
اذا حدا عم يشتغل مع السعوديه
كده انكتبوا انقطع الصوت عنه انقطع
الارسال
للسخريه
الان لما بيعمل طلب من هذا النوع يعني
وبيقول هذا الكلام هل هو متوقع انه يعني
دول الخليج هتجيء تساعده يعني مثلا الان
بعد هذا كله
طبعا جمهور طبعا اليوم همم
النظام الاقتصادي بلبنان راح الناس همم
ثلاث سنين كده
دائما بيفتش على اشخاص كرمال لحد عليهم
الصوديوم هو يذكر السعوديه
عندي لك سؤال يعني يا جينو صراحه مين مفيد
اكتر رونالدو ولا حسن نصر الله
رونالدو و و و و وكثير من الاشياء
والتفاصيل يعني الموضوع كانت يعني جميله
ومفيده وجميله حتى للدوري السعودي نصر
الله ايش هنستفيد نحن منه
مليار دولار ما بيفتكر بس الاستهلاك بيصير
بيقولوها شفته لو بس الخليجيه بساعدونا
احنا ماشي حالنا طيبغضوا النظر انه تحت
حزب الله وتحت حكم حزب الله وصلنا لهون
ومشال عون وانا
طلع نصر الله دفع عنه الوقت
صار كل الافكار تبعون انه اعطونا مصاري
للناس اللي هو اتاكيندم ليل نهار
الوقت
كالعاده على فشله همم
على العموم غرائب نصر الله لا تنتهي طبعا
شكرا لك على هذه المداخله كان معنا من
واشنطن السياسي اللبناني عادي شكرا لك